ええええええ
me
みなさんこんにちは10校の3年生ですねと今紹介にあずかりました大野3月です
今日はす行こうって何だろうと題しまして
皆さんにまあひょっとしたら役に立つかもしれない
そういう話をしていきたいとおもいますどうぞよろしくお願いします
タイトルになっている遂行ですけどまぁ皆さん大まかないい人いうかこうすればいいん
だろうなぁというのは知ってると思います
どこまでちょっと聞きたいんですけど自分の書いた文章にこれまで推敲したことがある
よって人手を挙げてくださいぜひ
まあで何とかしないで大丈夫です
はいありがとうございますまあほぼ全員だと思うんですけど
じゃあここでもう1個いきましょう自分の文章に
委員会つまり1つの文章に22遂行したことがあるよって人はどうでしょう
パンチラホラーライブでりますよねー
じゃあ3回印象はどうでしょう
もっと減りましたありがとうございますまあ僕はもう必要なら5回でも10回でも遂行
はするんですけど
まあ
お前なんですと一からそんなエアそうに水硬性こういったようなってこういうのあると
思うんで
僕がこのてレックスというイベントで立つんだっている理由を簡単に説明したいと思い
ます
主な原因はこの読めますかねコモドこれ藤村じゃなくて藤村なんですよ
まあ島崎藤村の
父さんのことなんですけどこの子もの藤村文学賞という賞で
8優秀賞
に写ってますけどいう主将を頂いたので今僕はこの団長に立っていますででどんなこと
を書いたかと言いますと
おととしの夏ですね
伊豆外にある御蔵島という島人
同学校の選択旅行というモデル行きました
このチーロ船に乗っているかとかと一緒に泳いだりもしたんですけど
問題は夜ライトツアーというものがあってそれで星を見に行ったんです
ヘッドそうですね泊まっているホテルから車に乗り込んで
10分ぐらい行くともうあの辺りに街灯が全然なくなって真っ暗になってもうそれこそ
本当に後ろ不毛ばかりかはちょっと微妙ですけどもう本当にこれぐらい事例な星が見え
てこれオリオン座なんて冬の星座なんて夏バーこれ見えなかったんですけどそんな話は
どうでもいい
多くてほんとこれくらいすごいのが見えて
近江寺島すげえなんたんです
えっと殺菌は消化にもあったんですけどこれで守り体なのでこういうホストラミちゃん
とやっぱり
星の名前とか星座の名前とかが気になってくるんですね
そこで役に立つのがそう
iphone
なんか空の方に向けるとその方のホストか星座の名前を教えてくれるアプリがあるので
ペットそれでなんか人通りアージェ双子座とか双子座と入れています
あれ白鳥座なーとかあれこと座とかやって
で夜空に目を戻すんですけどそこで僕は愕然とします
小柴全然見えなくなっちゃうんです
あの iphone の機能もちろん大抵にはしてたんですけどあの
夜空があまりにもくらいで iphone の方
わずか中にでも十分眩しくてまたスポットライトぐらい眩しいで寝たいと思います
でもほんと女がくらっちゃってさっきまで34どうせ車では軽く見えてたのが良い通せ
ぐらいまでしか見えなくなっちゃいました
ってそんな驚くべき体験をつづった星を見てで
8僕は心藤村文学賞の優秀賞どういうものを受賞して受賞させていただき
今こんなところになっています
さて本題に入りましょう
皆さん文章を書くのは好きですか
なんかまぁ引きそうじゃないですけどまあ当然だと思います
よっぽどの文章愛好家とかじゃない限りへまあ文章そう
なんか弾きで書くとかそういうことはできないと思います
なぜかというと文章があるのが辛いからですよね
でまぁそのにでが最後とする時っていうのはなにかの調整力が働くか何かメリットが
あるかなので
これから皆さんに文章を書く上でのメリットをご紹介いたしましょう
1つ達成がまあこれは当然ですね
2つねこれお金のイラストリースですけど実利
例えばこの藤村文学賞を受賞した僕の場合だと
なんと往復料往復交通費た金がかの旅行が出来て
消費税と側の数万円馬がもらえて受賞パーティーでおいしい食べ物が織田家にいっぱい
食べられちゃった
こんな実利がありました
まあここまでうまくいくのは少数派だと思いますけどこんな虫のいい話を聞いてブース
を書きたくなってきちゃったそこのあなたに
今日は大野隆部ペット応ドリューのブースを書く極意をお伝えいたしましょう
1とりあえず書く
に3校
山水煌4す行こうごす行こう
まあ人間間違える間違えたりどうしても完璧にはできない生き物なのでまぁそういう
やっぱり
直すとかが必要なんですね
足からスイ香水こう言ってんですけどそもそもす行こうってどういう意味の言葉なん
でしょう
パッと思いつくのは
こういうふうに誤字とか脱字とか
あと余分に入っちゃったエンジンってを見ますこれ縁寿とかを正しい状態に治すことな
んですけど
僕はそういうふうに間違いを正しだ味が遂行ではないと思うんですね
とりあえず辞書のを見てみましょう公然
詩文を作るのに軸をさまざまに考えること
どうもそういう構成とかそう言うにはその言葉ではないようです
これは塩とその水工程言葉のもとになった孤児体語が由来しているんですね
じゃあその故事成語も見てみましょう
唐の詩人関東がこの相互室月下のもなんかお坊さんがこういう治療の場合姉も多そうと
してるんですよ
でそういう情景をしに書こうとしたんですけどこのも8こういう状況を書くときにもう
オスっていう表現がいいかパーも叩くっていう表現がいいか迷ってしまって
えっそれで叩く買うって人に相談したっていうのがこの水耕っていう言葉の由来なわけ
で
だから決してそういう度5時を治すとかそういうだけじゃないってことだけちょっと頭
に留めておいてください
それじゃあ実際に遂行でたりする度に乗って話をします
基本的にはネット子じゅんこ館伍長
05:00
この5人っての僕の造語で後でちょっと説明しますけどこの4つを整えることがと僕は
考えています
じゃあ地帯の分で見てみましょう
増弾リンゴを太郎は食べたした
た甘リングを食べた
まあこれなんか上はちょっと語順が
おかしい感じがすると思いますそれに比べてしたが
単語団子は上げて時場所に収まってる感じがするしという人が多いんじゃないでしょう
か
まあこれ個人個人の感覚なんで上のほうがいいよとかも人はぜひそうの道を突っ走って
ください
もし僕がこの状況で上を使うとしたらそれはもうこの林檎っていう単語を強調したくて
里五里五里コってやりたいときはこの上を使うといいと思います
もう一個見てみましょう
私は昨日山に登った
昨日私は山に登った
これどっちも成立してそう成立してそうですし実際どっちも越冬口にだして読んでる分
にはおかしくないんですけど
こうやって文字として見た時にですね
漢字2文字クラス山のところって
すごく子夕飯ぽくありません昨日やがって
まぁ実際検索したがそんなやまないんですけどなんかん
そうですよねデコだわねとこそ公とかお前何言ってなーとかよく思う人多いと思うん
ですけど
人間ですねそうやってなんか文章のぜ街に入ってなんかじっくり読んでる時っていう時
にこういうと語りをちょっと覚えちゃうとなんかその分その世界から
っす覚め夢から覚めてしまうみたいなことがあるんでこういうビデオはなトゲみたいな
のでも全部
たく取得
必要があると思いますでどうやってた靴かっていうとまあそうですね昨日前にもって来
ちゃえばいいんですよ
昨日私は山に登ったあってこうすれば解決します
こういうこと高いのがこの語順ですまあ読んで字の如くですね
次行ってみましょう
未来的に活躍するだろう将来的に活躍するだろう
これはパンと美玲上おかしいでしょうっていう人も多いと思います
そうですね未来できっていうた子はこういう文脈じゃ使いませんし使えません
でまぁこういうのは辞書引くと載ってたりするんですけど
辞書より良いものがあって google の検索ですね
そういうところで検索するとあの実際どれぐらいに使われているかとか
文章中でどういうふうに使われているとかも分かるので
こういう表現を書いていいのかなぁと思うときは google で検索してみたり
するとよくわかると思います
もう一つ見てみましょうこれは
割と説明しやすいですけど
クイズの答えを書いたクイズの解答氏ぬした
そうですね8上のほうがなんか柔らかい活用すると思うんですけど基本的には8および
の漢字を使った熟語
回答十勝 new とかですね
そういうのはわりとなんでしょうカチッとした公文書とか何かそういうきっちりした
イメージの文に仕上がります
なので例えばこの例だと上は読み物とか日とか比較時はこういうようじゃないと思い
ますし
下はあの活動報告とかそういうのがあったときにはこう
いう表現のほうが素晴らしいと思います
でこういう単語炭鉱のイデー4を
何でしょう考えてる以上同士で置き換えていくのが互換です
次行きましょう
昨日私は山に登った昨日私は山に登った
まあこうやって当店一つ入れるだけでも分そのリズムがちょっと変わるんですよ
こういうことを考えるのが五鳥っていうところになります
実際のなんか5条の意味たらちょっと離れてるみたいですけどそれこそ区御成整える
ために伍長というタイトルをつけさせて頂きました8編を過程をつける以外にも5町
止める方法あって例えばちょっと文章がなかったか
てしまって申し訳ないんですよ星の輝きが明るくなっていったのが印象的だ
という文を言ったことが印象的だって帰るだけでもリズムがほんのちょっとバーって
でまぁこういうの
考えると文章のリズムが良くなります
まあそんなこと言っても文章のリズムとかわかんねぇよって人もいると思うんで
まあそのリズムの整え方をご紹介します
自分の書いた文章
音読するんですね
ねあのー
音読してみてそうするとここはちょっと引っかかるなーとかここ語呂悪いなーみたいな
ところが出てくると思うので
まぁそこに点を入れてみたり類似語でいいかいてみたりしてそして一人を繰り返して
いればとそのうち
リズムがいい文章が書けています
最後です昨日私は山に登った
昨日私は山に登った文書自体が同じで漢字で書いてるがひらがなで書いているかが違う
ということですね
先ほど伍長のところでも言ったんですけど感情を使うと地本的には固めちょっと
きちっとしたイメージになると思います
でんこ8そうですねこういうことを考えるのが5時いってもこれ
辞書に載ってないんだ後で
なんか私が作った観光で申し訳ないんですけどこういうふうにえーっと感じかひらがな
かを考えるところです
まあねこれは僕どちらかというと上のほうが好きですね
まあここまで来るともう個人個人の
カンカンというか好き好きなのでどっちでもいいと思います
もちろんひらがなの方がこれは良いんじゃねーかっていう単語もあって例えば上の一つ
ですね
とこれは8感じでも2次でもなく平場まで12と書くのが良いと思います
2つまではひらがなでいけるんですけどちょっと3つまで行っちゃうとなんか不自然な
ので
そういうときは一つ二つ三つって表現を改めたほうがいいと思いますね
でしたてんてん
こういうふうに何か読めなくはないけど
パッと見だとちょっと運指かかるちっかかるなぁみたいな
えっと熟語こういうのはもういっそ枚まで徒歩返されたほうが僕はいいと思います
ヘッドさえ
長縄遂行をどうやめたみたいな話をしてきましたけど
この中にはそもそもを遂行するための文章が書けねえよってな文書陰でよって人も
少なかれていると思います僕もそのクチなのでよく分かります体とそういう人がどう
すればいいかアドバイスを一つ教えしたいと思いま
ますとりあえず
ブースを一様を書いてみましょう1両でいいのででそれ間違ってでマートバラ直しだり
は全然
可能などで今の時代ワードとかでもすぐ消したり修正したりできるので
でそれで一度書いてきたものを遂行してみましょう
ってその分が自分の納得いくものに仕上がったら8それにまたさらに位
g を出してそれを遂行してみましょうそれを繰り返していけばきっと自分でも納得の
いく良い文章が書けていることと思います
以上では僕の話を終わりますありがとうございました